c'est qu'on sert à rien on sert plus à
rien
[Musique]
les habitants des quartiers ils ont de
plus l'espoir qu'on vienne les aider
c'est fini at on entendu sinon c'est
quoi ce serait contraire là on a envie
de me qui leur donne une faute on donne
une vraie info la cintiq 300 kg a été
trouvée nez quand c'est possible
cette gamme est enregistrée fait comment
voyez vous je sais pas je vais pas se
voir
pourquoi je devrais risquer ma carrière
parce nous donne les moyens de travail
il faut arrêter avec les suites et tout
le monde s'en - le préfet le premier
juste airlines du journal pour faire le
monde
tu veux devenir officier cette opération
devant les chefs d'accusation raquette
et trafic de drogue en bande organisée
c'est pasqua
ça fait 20 ans que je fais ce métier moi
je crois tu sais tout mais tu sais rien
tu sais rien des quartiers nord on a
failli crever là bas
[Musique]
toi tu rentres chez toi tu risques que
rien
tu as ma parole
tu fais ce métier moi je le fais je
comprends pas pourquoi je ne comprends
pas comment d'en arriver là en fait
[Musique]